if the world warms by one degree the
Arctic is ice-free for half the year
opening the legendary Northwest Passage
for ships tens of thousands of homes
around the Bay of Bengal are flooding
hurricanes begin hitting the South
Atlantic severe droughts in the western
US caused shortages in global grain and
meat markets this could be our world
plus 1 degree at 1 degree additional
warming - today we're likely to see the
emergence of new deserts in the western
half of the United States from Texas in
the south right up to the Canadian
border is in danger of becoming new
hyper arid areas where really no crops
can be grown at all the Earth's average
temperature has always fluctuated and a
variable climate isn't unusual it's the
pace of climate change today that's
unprecedented
if you had asked us 10 or 20 years ago
what would be the impact of 1 or 2
degrees
additional warming we would say well
probably we can live with that NASA
climate scientist James Hansen was one
of the first to sound the alarm about
global warming the threat has only
escalated as he struggled to be heard
what we realize now is that we're
getting so close to tipping points that
we're gonna have to stabilize
atmospheric co2 studying climates in the
past is given Hansen a window onto the
dangers posed by global warming in the
last million years has never been more
than 1 degree Celsius warmer than it is
now what we are doing now with the
human-made greenhouse gases is an order
of magnitude larger and it's being
introduced very rapidly